is there something you can say about the
power structure
the hierarchy of the median cartel that
you interacted with
was uh was it a dictatorship where pablo
ran
everything was there a bunch of power
centers
was it like a company whether you have
ceo cto kind of thing
and then there's like managers and all
those kinds of things what's the
like how did it run from a leadership
perspective
i understand that about five of them got
together
and made this i would call it an
insurance company
and uh now known as the medellin cartel
and i didn't see any difference each one
of them had their own business
and uh their people from the jungle or
wherever made the cocaine gave it to
them
and they shipped it and uh so it didn't
it didn't seem to be any
any power play between them at all but
my main contact was jorge ochoa
and pablo escort bar was right there and
i saw
plenty of stuff for him too it's strange
that they didn't betray each other
regularly
you know uh greed makes men betray each
other
how do you explain that how much
betrayal did you see
i didn't see any absolutely none
if if he shipped his 100 kilos he got
paid for it
if the other one uh ship tears i'm sure
they got paid for it
how do you explain that well there was
no need to
the money was just unbelievable you
think about 500 kilos in the plane
at 50 000 dollars a kilo at the time
and they paid five thousand dollars to
ship it
and they made five thousand without even
touching it they just had
somebody to load it onto the airplane i
gave it to their man in miami
they gave it to whoever it belonged to
by the
by the marks on the duffel bags so they
was making just
untold millions just uh
no reason but greed can blind men i
you know it's still
it's still strange to me that there was
not more betrayal
it speaks to something else perhaps
that's bigger than money
maybe maybe not but it seems like just
like
in the casino like you mentioned uh we
um
get accustomed to the whatever level of
money we have we get accustomed very
quickly
yes and then there's a tension that's
natural between human beings
and when that tension combined with
money
combined with power combined with like
you mentioned beautiful women
and a bit of violence it seems that
betrayal should be commonplace but it's
not
it wasn't not at all they said carlos
later i don't know he betrayed anybody
but he started that
he was running cocaine through the
bahamas and he had the island
i didn't go i was offered to fly with a
dc-3 with that but i didn't like it
so i had my route through the old wells
in louisiana
and uh so i thought you weren't going to
change but uh he
he talked a lot and i don't know he
betrayed but they didn't like him
yeah so as you expand there could be
tensions that
yeah that lead to conflict colombia was
like you said an ultra-violent place
how did you survive who protected you i
was a hero
they they liked me i mean i was just
treated royally all i did
i would come over el banco there's a
radio station at the forks of the
magdalena river
i believe at 7 20 if i remember right on
the am and i'd fly in at 10 000 feet and
i'd see below me there'd be a cessna
and i'd wiggle my wings and he'd wiggle
his and i'd fall in behind him and we
might go 100 200 miles
i'd land on some jungle strip or some uh
banana plantation and they'd fuel me up
i could eat
steak in the night it was just like
treated royally and
i mean take off the next morning
whenever i wanted to it was just like
that was protected
and i was i was honored guest
it wasn't anything like in that movie
putting you putting a gun to your head
and taking your sunglasses
and betting so one time i uh complained
to um
jorge ochoa that the runway was pretty
short that they were using
and i went back down and it looked like
los angeles international they had
bulldozers in there
had that thing 5 000 feet long and just
like just the next week it was
all done the jungle was gone and clay
put up there and
and all the while you were not afraid
you were treated like royalty
yes there i was i was afraid when i
landed in the united states
you